- [Narrator] In most of the world,
horseracing is a fast-paced,
head-spinning event.
But here on Japan's
northernmost island, Hokkaido,
the races move ...
(quirky music)
A little bit slower.
Ban'ei is a form of horseracing
found only in Hokkaido
in which draft horses pull heavy sleds
down a 200 meter dirt track.
The sleds can range from
900 to 2,000 pounds,
so Ban'ei horses are often twice as big
as their speedy counterparts.
(quirky music)
Kikuchi Kazuki has been a Ban'ei jockey
for the past nine years.
But the history of this
race goes back much further.
- [Narrator] The popularity
of the races grew,
and starting in the 1950s
there were four cities
hosting races across Hokkaido.
However, in recent years
interest has waned.
And today the races are
only held at this racetrack.
But that didn't stop Kikuchi.
- [Narrator] Pulling one-ton
sleds is no easy task.
But these draft horses
race only every two weeks.
And in-between, they're
well taken care of.
- [Narrator] And for
first time spectators,
seeing Ban'ei horses
can be a bit of a shock.
- [Narrator] There have been
signs that Ban'ei racing
may be regaining popularity.
Either way, Kakuchi is happy
to be part of this tradition.